hoy Francia anunció orgullosa que
después de Portugal y de Bélgica es el
tercer país de la Unión Europea que
tiene llena sus reservas de gas para
pasar el invierno pero ojo esto no
significa que el 100% del consumo esté
garantizado sino Sólo dos tercios del
gas que consumen habitualmente los
franceses durante el invierno por lo
mismo los distribuidores de gas llaman a
los franceses a ahorrar y advierten de
posibles tensiones durante el invierno
esto ocurre a dos días de que el
gobierno de Manuel macron presente su
plan de seguridad energética con el que
pretende además ahorrar un 10% de
energía hoy también el ministro de
economía Bruno lember se reunió con los
distribuidores de energía para hacerlo
firmar una carta de conducta para que se
comprometan a tener precios estables y
más claros con los consumidores
recordemos que los clientes particulares
pero sobre todo empresas están muy
afectados por el alza de los precios de
la energía muchas de estas empresas
dicen estar al borde de la quiebra lo
más novedoso de estas reuniones que el
gobierno se portará como garante de los
clientes en caso de no puedan pagar su
factura hoy además comienza a regir el
techo el precio de la energía es un
acuerdo de la Unión Europea la
diferencia entre el precio de producción
y de venta irá para los estados para que
financian justamente ayudas para las
personas que están sufriendo con esta
crisis energética hoy también en las
estaciones de servicio de Francia en un
12% de ella se ha habido problemas de
suministro según el portavoz del
gobierno no estamos todavía en una
situación de escasez